erin good morning how are we doing um
so my sister is moving back home
um from philadelphia and she is
transitioning
and i don't know how to tell how to talk
to my eight-year-old son about that
okay i don't know how to kind of support
her but
shelter him um okay so oh i feel kind of
stuck
tell me about the the journey here how
have you been a part of this
walking this with your sister and
what does moving home back mean walk me
through what all these things mean
um well i kind of had i kind of
keep my distance a little bit um she had
lived
near us like we're all a very tight
family in the same town
and then she went to philadelphia to be
a missionary for a year and then started
taking testosterone to transition
okay um one quick second aaron for those
listening
um for those who say someone is
transitioning that means they
are yeah from a woman to a man right
so they're going to transition their
gender from one to another
yeah and is is she's been taking
hormones
and i'm assuming she's been working with
folks and so she going to have gender
reassignment surgery
i i think so in the future but i don't
think we're there
quite yet okay um but she also has like
bpd and um schizophrenia so she's coming
home to get help with that too
okay so i just kind of feel like that's
a lot to
i don't know if i should just stay away
that's not very supportive
yeah so when you say stay away versus be
supportive walk me through what that
means
oh i don't know maybe just like keeping
the distance so there's
peace and no uncomfortableness or
arguments i guess that's not really
how a family works but yeah i don't know
many families that don't have
don't have arguments do you have
brothers and sisters mom and dad still
in the picture
my mom yeah our dad committed suicide
when my sister was like nine
so i that was some of the early trauma
that she had
um and then i have another sister and
brother and we all live like within a
couple blocks of each other once she
gets home
so and so when your sister moves home
is your sister gonna be living with your
mom yeah
and what does help look like for
schizophrenia and the bipolar
um seeing the specialist for that the
i don't remember what it's called um not
a psychiatrist for the
people with the brain specialties like a
neurologist
yeah yeah okay but she's getting medical
care basically
yeah she will be when she gets here yeah
okay and where is she living now
philadelphia so she actually comes home
this weekend
so here's um there's two separate things
here
number one and i hear you asking two
separate questions one is what you do
and one how do you talk to your
eight-year-old right
yeah so if i'm you um
i would be there when
my sister comes home and i would be
there
with the biggest
strongest hug i could possibly muster
and i would be there to
greet them with is as much love as i
have capacity to put forth
and that is not a judgment on the mental
health issues that's not a
judgment or indictment on the gender
transition
none of that that is i'm your sister and
i love you
and we've all been through a lot as a
family
and my guess is you and i could probably
talk for a couple hours and unpack
just a history right of
of ups and downs and challenges your
family's endured
and at the end of the day my default
setting is always going to be love
always if you feel that you're unsafe
if the bipolar and the schizophrenia
puts you or your kid or your family in a
position
where y'all are safe then of course
you've got to draw some pretty firm
boundaries
i also know that living with or
in relationship with someone who is
acutely bipolar or acutely schizophrenic
by the way
those two diagnostics don't work
together so somebody somewhere
hopefully she'll get better care
i think the last i looked those two
can't be comorbid which means they can't
be co-occurring psychiatric issues
i may need to get somebody write me in
if i'm wrong on that but i think i'm
right there
um but they are commonly just when
psychiatrists are throwing stuff up
against the wall but hopefully she'll
get the
the psychiatric care she needs if you
ever feel unsafe of course draw those
boundaries
um but i think your heart will struggle
with
just cutting your sister out
and leaving your mom to just figure it
out
and i may be wrong there but that's what
i'm getting from your heart
as it relates to your eight-year-old
tell me about your eight-year-old
um i don't know he's awesome um and
right now he just knows that
um she i just said she has a nickname
so i don't know why sometimes people
want nicknames so we'll just call her
this
okay um so is she asking the family to
refer to her by a new name
oh yeah okay walk me through what that
process looks like for your family
um what is your sister requested of the
family
oh to just completely accept her as this
new
person right and so her and i have had
some
tough conversations yeah about me not
being ready to talk to my son about it
okay and that's bringing up tears in
your heart tell me about that
no i don't know i just feel bad
that she's gone through so much trauma
and i want her to get
help for that and i don't necessarily i
don't
agree that this is the way that you fix
it
gotcha and so here's
here's um you've got
um um let me let me
back out a little bit i think that i
want you to honor let me say this way i
want you to honor
and mourn um the transition of your
sister
you had a picture of your sister you had
dreams for your sister
you know she's been through a
nightmarish childhood
and regardless of what you think about
gender transition surgeries right
you know somebody who is is going down
that path
is struggling with who they are who
they've been where they want to go
who they see in the mirror who has loved
them who hasn't loved them and that's a
nightmare for anybody to walk forget the
morality of it and forget the politics
of it and forget the
the all the stuff that surrounds that
nobody wishes that journey on anybody
because it's a nightmare
right i've sat with too many students
and too many people in that world
and so you ache for your sister you
mourn for your sister and i want you to
honor that okay and i don't know if you
spent some time by yourself
um or with someone that you care about
just crying over the
pain for your sister but i think that's
worthy of being done okay
that just shows you care about your
sister okay yeah yeah
um as for your eight-year-old um
here's i actually i knew this particular
call was common
and so i i don't have a lot of expertise
working with
kids in this situation i've got a lot of
opinions
and i've got a lot of my own biases
and things that i lean towards but i
didn't have a lot of expertise and so i
called a couple of
therapists who work with kids and got
their
insights and here is
here's a really a direct approach that
and it's important to remember a couple
things about eight-year-olds and also
um to remember something between about
eight-year-olds
y'alls 2 relationship the first thing is
is
kids don't carry i don't want to say
baggage but that's the word i'm going to
use here
they don't carry the baggage they don't
understand the political fervor around
things they don't understand the
historical
issues here um he just knows that i'm
just gonna make up names here
um he just knows that aunt becky now is
asked to be called uncle steve
right and there's sometimes a direct
line to an eight-year-old
this is uncle steve is is trying to
to match what he feels on the inside
with um
uh what he looks like on the outside and
so the next time we see
aunt becky he's at uh she is asking us
to call
him he and asking us to call him uncle
steve
and we're just going to call him uncle
steve and you can choose to say
that's what he's asking it's going to be
confusing for us and we're going to ask
for some grace
and aunt becky is gonna have to remind
us a few times
about the the new name she'd like to be
called and um
we're just gonna honor that that's one
way of approaching it
and most young children will go okay
and when they see somebody new for the
first time when they see
um somebody who's transitioned gender or
starting to
and maybe wearing more masculine
traditionally masculine clothes more
traditionally feminine clothes
they'll ask questions because
eight-year-olds ask questions and that's
where i ask
everybody to be mutually respectful of
each other right
and so if someone's coming to the house
and they're transitioning
understand that it's different for an
eight-year-old right the other side of
that is
you can tell your son anything you want
your son's gonna pick up
what to do by you
by the conversations you have by how
tense you are
by how not tense you are by how not
welcoming you are by how welcoming you
are
and if you do not want your um sister
transitioning brother to be around your
kid
then make that value judgment call it
what it is and accept it for what it's
for the the repercussions that it's
going to be right
and if you want to continue a
relationship while your sister gets well
while your sister continues to walk
through who she is and who she feels
like and how that interacts with past
traumas and all that
then you're going to have recurring
conversations with your son
i like to look at these conversations in
my house
as not as acute issues like what do we
do with this particular situation or
that particular situation but i like to
back out 30 000 feet
and let my kids know when people are
hurting
when people are struggling when people
make decisions that are different than
we in this house make
or that are the same as that we in this
house make
our default setting is love and our
default setting is you're welcome at our
table
and that's just a guiding principle in
our house and
i do give my kids permission to ask
questions i do give them permission to
have judgments they're eight and five
right or eight and four and a half
um but they're allowed to
question and allowed to wonder and
allowed to ask hard things and i'm going
to give them the best answer i can but
that's always going to start from a
place of hospitality and love
right so when i'm saying those things
tell me what you're thinking because i
know you've been down those roads in
your own heart and head before
um thinking when i have to be
honest with him and tell him everything
that's going on um
and he'll probably understand it's
probably more of a bigger deal to me
than it is to him
i don't i think it'll be a big deal i
think
uh because it's going to be so different
and so unique and it will
it will spur all kinds of questions like
you can just change that and
is that something i just didn't want him
to think about that as
ever you know i didn't want it to make
him question who he was
right and i think i think that's when i
talk about um eight-year-olds don't have
that
that type of baggage um okay
most most eight-year-olds like okay and
then he's gonna go on i've had my son
ask all kinds of different questions
from why are the
our pets mating too why are um you know
what i mean
you mean uh two two two women can get
married
and two and just asking question after
question and
yeah i just answer it direct and
honestly
and it's always i always brace for it
right like
oh here's the here's the sex question
and then i say
yeah and he goes okay hey let's go play
soccer and it's just
right and then he moves on this one will
be different because he he
has a reference point for aunt becky
right and that's going to be different
now
yeah and that's where it'll be your
responsibility to make sure
that your sister who's asking to be
called
by a new name is graceful especially
with a young kid right
right this is just different and if
somebody who's got bipolar schizophrenia
is unable to
also be mutually hospitable as people
are trying to
wrap their heads around what's going on
um then that may be where someone's
gonna be ugly to your son then you
protect your son
right gotcha yeah okay um but
let me ask you this question do you want
your do you want your sister in your
life
yeah yeah you said that with hesitancy
i mean yeah it's gonna be a lot of
um adjustments and a lot of hard work
just like
but it's worth it all right i want you
to hang on to that
last statement that people are worth it
and the transgender conversation i may
do um we may do a whole show on it one
day just to kind of talk through the
nuances and the this isn't that's and
um but i want you to hang on to
that phrase she's worth it um as i was
just saying i'm sorry i interrupted
myself
we often look at the transgender
conversation because it's such a third
rail and it's hard people understand
on every side of the situation um but i
like to again
back way out of that conversation people
are different they make judgments they
make
decisions with their bodies with their
minds with their actions that we
absolutely disagree with we disagree
with it scientifically we disagree with
it morally we
disagree with it religiously whatever
your quote unquote disagreements are
and i want everybody to always back out
and remember that people are worth it
people are worth it and that makes life
hard and it makes it confusing and it
makes it up and down and frustrating
and so is relationships so our brothers
and sisters so our moms and dads
and so um aaron thank you for your heart
thank you for working through this and
trying to love your sister trying to
love your son
and trying to figure out new territory
as you go
um and again you end up on two places
right
hospitality or everybody's welcome are
going to figure that out or
i've got some value boundaries and i'm
just going to draw some lines
and we're going to live with what those
boundaries look like
and i'm not going to let you off the
hook and give you
give you the answer but i want you to
remember that last line that
that relationships are worth it